speaking of which Donald Trump throwing
democracy in the toilet and flushing it
10 to 15 times at 2 30 in the morning we
knew he was up to something weird in the
middle of the night didn't we Donald
Trump saying that Kerry Lake
should be installed as the governor of
Arizona you know if you go back and look
at the history of generally speaking
overwhelmingly the 20th century but also
to some degree the 21st and you look at
leaders who were quote installed
it's not a particularly good history and
that is exactly what Donald Trump is now
demanding happen in the middle of the
night Donald Trump posting to his
platform truth social
well call it what you want quote massive
numbers of quote and fully capitalized
broken
voting machines in Republican districts
on Election Day capital letters
everywhere none of them make sense
mechanics sent in to quote fix them made
them worse Carrie had to be taken to a
Democrat area which was working
perfectly to vote now understand that
none of that is true
her opponent ran the election this is
yet another criminal voting operation so
obvious Kerry Lake should be installed
governor of Arizona this is almost as
bad as the 2020 presidential election
remember it's almost as bad because
nobody's the bigger victim than Trump
which the unselect committee refuses to
touch because they know it was capital F
fraudulent
look at what is happening here this went
from Summer 2020 well you know
there might be problems that Democrats
take advantage of because of mail-in
voting and early voting no evidence of
it but it was a much smaller claim to I
won I won and they stole it from me in
November of 2020.
now to install the loser
install the loser make her the governor
even though she actually lost if we win
it's a fair election if we don't bring
out the pitchforks demand a new
elections say it's fraud and blah blah
blah blah blah now one of the craziest
things about this
is that Kerry lake is still insisting
that they're going to get this one back
now much like with all of these people
we don't know to what degree are they
grifters to what degree are they Liars
to what degree are they victims
I am struggling to believe that Kerry
lake has even a one percent belief that
they are going to somehow get her to be
the governor of Arizona and yet she just
posted as a reply to Donald Trump's
truth quote arizonans have no faith and
trust in our elections and what's
notable is she capitalizes Faith trust
and elections just like Trump does very
weird she goes on to say our election
officials are incompetent or worse they
have failed us the fake news ignores our
fake elections and expect us to just
quote move on
we won't America will not survive if we
don't demand election reform now do we
think for a second that Kerry Lake
really believes she is going to be
appointed the governor of Arizona
installed as the governor of Arizona
declared the winner of the governor of
Arizona race
I am really struggling to believe that
and what I think is actually going on
here is that this is Carrie Lake's
continued addition to be Donald Trump's
vice presidential running mate in 2024.
Marjorie Taylor green has made it clear
she wants to be Trump's running mate in
2024 and Kerry lake is making it clear
as well and as I've said before not all
of the people claiming that 2020 was
stolen really believe it some of them
say it because they realize that it is
the thing you're supposed to say if you
are showing your allegiance to Donald
Trump's team
and I believe that that is part of what
is going on here as well if you believe
that Kerry Lake believes she is going to
be the governor of Arizona let me know
in the comments and make sure you're of
course subscribed on YouTube in order to
be able to comment at youtube.com the
davidpackman show we talk about it all
the time one of the biggest contributors
to climate change is deforestation did
you know that 15 of deforestation is due
to toilet paper production alone
according to the nrdc that's why I love
our sponsor real paper real paper makes
a sustainable toilet paper no trees it
uses 100 bamboo a bamboo stock can keep
being harvested indefinitely no
deforestation real paper is certified by
the forest Stewardship Council for a
responsible harvesting of the bamboo
grass used for their paper another
contributor to climate change change the
plastic that the toilet paper comes
wrapped in that's why real paper
involves no plastic packaging and best
of all real paper looks and feels just
like normal traditional toilet paper the
cost is similar it is fantastic on their
website you can do a one-time purchase
or set up an easy recurring subscription
the way that I did my audience gets 30
off your first order plus free shipping
go to realpaper.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman at checkout the link is down
below